well for many of us on the back benches
who came to the conclusion we couldn't
carry on as we were with boris johnson
weeks if not months ago um
i'm pleased that the the cabin have got
to this point eventually at least two
cabinet members i think other people be
weighing up their their options
uh but i mean clearly the the pincher
debacle
and the prime minister sending ministers
out to defend the indefensible and then
saying actually that admitting actually
eventually the truth was dragged out in
that he did know
that uh that pincher had been
investigated and found to have been
involved in shenanigans while he was a
minister i mean that was the icing on
the cake for them i'm not surprised
we're at this situation this now needs
to be resolved quickly boris johnson
needs to go how he needs to go before
summer recess yeah he's not but he's not
a guy prone to you know um giving up is
he uh do you expect more cabinet
ministers to
resign in the coming hours and days
uh well that's up to them that's the
decision they've all got to make i think
they should have gone some time ago we
we could have avoided this situation but
we've got the 1922 they'll announce
tomorrow uh the rules and the timetable
for elections to the executive i think
we'll have an executive elected now who
will be
pro rule chains change and whatever the
cabinet do we will be changing i think
we'll be changing the rules before
summer recess uh to remove the prime
minister have a second confidence vote
within 12 months but do you think uh
before all that he can survive the
resignation of
you know chancellor and health secretary
if the prime minister can get people to
fill the roles i think we've still got a
vacant a vacant uh position for party
chairman he's got more vacancies now
than an out of season
uh seaside boarding house
but did you hear his apology he was on
um i don't know half an hour or so ago
45 55 minutes ago
accepting that it was a mistake
to appoint chris pincher apologizing
what will tory mps make of that
uh well i was actually with two former
loyalist uh conservative colleagues when
they got the text that the prime
minister actually going to be in the tea
room at four o'clock and colleagues
should come and join him but uh myself
and a few other um boris critics we
didn't seem to get that uh that text um
but it's it's too little too late from
the prime minister he's he's worn the
patience down of even his arch arch
loyalists and quite honestly he's warned
the public's uh tolerance of him down as
well a huge swathe of the population
that they're die-hard conservatives
they'll never vote labor never vote
liberal democrat they're just
disengaging with politics and this is
all down to the way that the prime
minister has conducted business in
number 10. right and you just mentioned
earlier if the
more cabinet ministers don't move
against him
you could change the rules of this
committee and the elections to the
committee and then have another
confidence vote i suppose my question is
will you be able to change the rules
will you win that and then
would you win another confidence vote
what's what's your thoughts
well it's all been one-way traffic since
the first confidence motion the the
after the by-elections uh there's a
considerable amount of buyers remorse
from colleagues who voted confidence in
the prime minister and quite honestly
the debacle over over the handling of
chris pincher uh he should never have
been in that position um
that has uh has put the tin lid on it
quite honestly so even arch former
boris loyalists on the back benches have
now completely
lost faith lost confidence and had
enough so it's time for boris to go
um he can drag this out for a few more
hours if he wants to
but i'm iron a lot of the party now
determined that he will be gone by
summer recess the sooner the better if
he does stick around what do you think
that chris pincher should do i mean
should he resign and therefore
you know provoke another gen
by-election
well he should resign um clearly uh he
he shouldn't be back in parliament um
until the party moves the rit it's a
conservative seat it was within our our
party's gift to move the writ before
recess or or after recess um i think
we've had enough by-elections at the
moment i think what we need is a a new
conservative leader then i i'd be very
confident that we could actually retain
the tamworth seat it's it borders on to
onto my seat of northwest leicestershire
i would be convinced that with a a new
party leader a new prime minister and
the right candidate we could retain
tamworth right and if uh
boris johnson does go who
do you think will
will replace him
i have no idea we have a mechanism for
that and if i were to back anyone at
this stage i'm sure it'd be the kiss of
death so
i'm not very good at backing the people
actually become the prime minister and
when i did back the person who became it
was boris johnson so i'm trying to put
that right now
and just on boris johnson where did it
you start going on was it partygate i
mean obviously
was
you know considerable element
but he's had he on the international
stage he's you know had pretty good
reports
domestically he's just stumbled from
crisis to crisis
i started losing faith in the prime
minister who i'd back through brexit and
for the leadership this time last year
when he made a move to try and remove
sagran brady who was chairman of the
1922 committee by putting
his own
person instead
that was a power grab but then we had
the owen patterson debacle i didn't vote
to
for that i didn't vote for the national
insurance increases i couldn't support
the rising corporation tax um
and
it's been downhill from there really
mark and just finally 30 seconds um how
do you think this all plays out now
it really depends uh if the rest of the
cabinets uh get a backbone and and move
against the prime minister and
and resign but
whatever happens i'm
i'm pretty convinced that boris
johnson's going to be uh
we're going to be having a leadership
election for the conservative party
quite rightly